We don't go to them and say,
hey, we've got electricity.
We're going to bring it to you.
We're going to bring
you modern entertainment
that electricity provide, no.
They're coming to us and saying,
we're so far off the grid,
we don't have any electricity,
we're using kerosene,
we have to carry the
kerosene hundreds of miles
to our village on
a regular schedule.
What little electricity
you have is coming
from some diesel generators.
It's not very efficient.
It's not very healthy.
Matter of fact, the
fumes are damaging
the insides of the monasteries
and things like that.
So our bringing electricity them
is for them a dream come true.
There are some landslides
which happened last month,
so the roads are not so good.
Now in good condition.
And secondly, if it rains,
it can be really risky
for us to even move ahead.
Because if we go ahead and
we get stuck in some area,
we can't either go
back or go forward.
Oh my god, it's tough.
[music playing]
What is the natural response
for you when you enter
a room that is not lit up?
To reach for a light switch.
And that is something
that these villagers
have never experienced.
Actually had tears of joy.
Just like looking back at
the caravan of vehicles
that were all coming together to
do this amazing thing together.